prêt pour en débattre nous sommes avec
un jean philippe tanguy porte-parole de
debout la france bonsoir jean philippe
tanguy merveille soit avec nous à ses
côtés pour en débattre denis jacquet
entrepreneurs merci à vous également
denis jacquet bonsoir monsieur joindre
donc je le disais un des deux françaises
qui va atteindre les 121 % du pib 1 du
jamais vu depuis soixante dix ans ça
fait trente neuf mille euros par part
français comme ça on comprend bien c'est
considérable qui va payer avec le long
de chômeurs qui explose le débat fait
rage depuis déjà plusieurs semaines
alors qu on sait qu évidemment l'argent
va difficilement rentrer dans les
caisses à vous l'honneur jean philippe
attendu eh bien écoutez
malheureusement le risque que c'est ce
que les travailleurs comme toujours les
classes moyennes paient c'est le grand
risque de cette dette c'est pour ça que
debout la france a beaucoup insisté sur
le fait que cette crise devait être le
début d'une rapide rond localisation des
emplois notamment des emplois
industriels pour recréer la richesse et
les gains de productivité qui seules
permettront de rembourser la dette car
si comme dans la crise de 2008 puis avec
françois hollande en 2012 on augmente
les impôts on va juste casser la
croissance sans jamais rembourser la
dette puisque entre 2008 et la crise par
un centime de dettes n'a été amortis
puisque seule la création de richesse
permet de rembourser sur la durée une
aide sans créer d'injustice sociale et
on voit bien que l'allemagne s'en est
sorti car elle a toujours conservé ses
emplois industriels
seule l'industrie permet dans la durée
de dégager les richesses nécessaires
c'est pour ça que nous on insiste
vraiment beaucoup sur le fabriqué en
france sur la relocalisation des emplois
et donc au final le savoir qui est ce
que c'est les riches ou les pauvres qui
doivent payer n'a pas beaucoup de sens
se dit qu'on s'est créé de l'emploi donc
par exemple pour l' isf
nous on demande que l' isf la
suppression de l'sf soit tout simplement
conditionné à des investissements en
france notamment dans les pme ce qui
permettrait une utilisation intelligente
de la richesse car effectivement si on
fait fuir les personnes qui ont du
capital avec la mondialisation telle
qu'elle est on se retrouve avec un sous
financement des entreprises
donc il faut vraiment pas fait
de moralisme d'idéologie face à cette
crise il faut être pragmatique et pour
le fabriquer en france
denis jacquet un discours de debout la
france qui qui devrait vous séduire en
tout cas en partie oui alors
effectivement y est il est toujours les
y est toujours les mots et leur contenu
au niveau des mots c'est difficile de se
poser à à quoi que ce soit mais que
notre amitié et 10 en ligne tout à
l'heure parce que bien évidemment
relocaliser c'est avant tout une
question de souveraineté espère qu'à un
moment donné quand où les commandes et
du gel hydroalcoolique un médicament un
masque et cours nous orthez simplement à
une pénurie totale pourquoi parce que
tout est fait depuis la chine
on s'aperçoit des conséquences d'une
délocalisation alors qu'ils étaient
souvent on oublie aussi la conséquence
d'une espèce d'associations ac
malfaisante entre le politique la grande
distribution elle consommateurs qui ont
cru à ce miracle du pouvoir d'achat en
disant qu'un prix toujours moins élevé
on oublie le deuil est juste de dire
qu'à un moment donné c'est moins de
marge c'est moins d'investissements et
moins d'emplois
donc on a voulu promettre effectivement
alors aux classes moyennes et aux
classes plus basse le vertige une
lumière mirifiques des prix bas mais à
un moment donné les prix bas c'est des
emplois en moins on s'en aperçoit trente
ans après c'est un petit peu tard mais
néanmoins c'est un bon moment de le voir
alors évidemment industriellement moi
j'aimerais bien que les emplois
reviennent ce qu'il faut bien comprendre
quand on est entrepreneur c'est que si
on fait revenir des industries chez nous
principalement elles ne créeront pas ou
peu d'emplois pourquoi parce qu'elles
seront pour être compétitive mécanisée
robotisés et automatisés pour parce
qu'aujourd'hui pour faire un masque
puisque c'est le grande de toujours le
grand moment du coc vide vous faites un
masque une machine aujourd'hui qu'elle
soit en chine ou en france elle débite
180 200 mille masques par jour
effectivement il ya aucune raison
qu'elles soient plus chers en france
mais c'est parce qu'il ya donc à mettre
autour ou beaucoup moins donc qu'il faut
pas non plus avoir le vertige de la
relocalisation et ça plus créatis de
souveraineté et d'indépendance
économique véritablement de massivement
d'emplois puis après monsieur a raison à
l'emploi à la demande ou pour l'instant
on ne sait pas le faire
on sait faire de l'industrie
2 comme on l'a fait et d'automobiles
serre qui emploie beaucoup de personnes
peu ou pas qualifiées
celle ci malheureusement elle n'existe
plus et celle qui se considère à faire
une industrie de haute qualification
pour l'instant on ne sait pas le faire
c'est pas qu'on en n'a pas le talent
c'est pas con on ne serait pas le faire
on a des grands ingénieurs des gens
extrêmement brillant mais pour l'instant
on n'a jamais su en france le faire
faire une industrie capable en un mot
comme en allemagne d'exporter parce que
je suppose toute une politique de
culture d'apprentissage d'investissement
en formation qu'on n'a pas fait
jusqu'ici mais néanmoins pour revenir
sur le prix de la dette est
effectivement je suis d'accord
aujourd'hui il y est c'est pts il faut
savoir que depuis qu'on l'a mis en place
a juste fait fuir ou minimum du minimum
140 milliards de milliards de francs ce
qui aujourd'hui pour être dans nos
caisses qui aujourd'hui aurait pu
investir dans notre pays qui aujourd'hui
aurait pu créer des emplois donc surtout
pas on va établir c'était c'est un pot
totalement stupide comme on avait avant
la taxe professionnelle qui fait que
plus on investissait plus on employait
plus on était puni donc ça c'est le
terrain voilà c'était une erreur
terrible de chiraquie duo de côté avait
supprimé l isf vaut surtout pas la
reconnaître c'est une vieille lune
communiste l isf c'est juste un trucage
aujourd'hui leurs droits sur leurs
dessins de télé partout beaucoup c'est
le débat qui fait rage aujourd'hui voilà
lié sait faire payer les plus hauts
salaires qui sont d'ailleurs patio on
parlait de la 3000 et quelques euros on
en entendait ici ou là dans l'est dans
les colonnes d voilà des quotidiens ça
vous fait bondir vous jean philippe
tanguy ce débat vous de juger également
comme denis jacquet un petit peu
d'arrière-garde
mais écoutez c'est pas que ça me fait
bondir c'est que malheureusement c'est
vraiment des vieilles solutions de
politiciens qui ont échoué en tout si
vous voulez nous à deux bouts la france
on n'est pas du tout contre imposer ceux
qui ont la chance de réussir et qui
peuvent faire preuve de solidarité c'est
qu'on veut que les emplois reviennent et
pour qui est de l'emploi il faut tout
simplement du financement
donc nous on était contre la suppression
gratuite j'ai envie de dire de liesse f
puisque malheureusement certaines
comédiennes certaine bourgeoisie
française aussi n'aime pas investir
l'industrie alors c'est à ça qu'on paie
ce qu'a dit monsieur avant il avait
raison c'est qu'on a une tradition en
france malheureusement plutôt
d'investissement dans la pierre plutôt
dans la rente au détriment de
l'industrie on le voit moi j'ai beaucoup
travaillé au japon on voit des vraies
différences c'est pour ça que debout la
france on veut faire de l'incitation on
veut faire du pragmatisme car on veut
tout simplement que ça réussisse et je
voulais aussi compléter ce que j'ai
monsieur sur la robotisation c'est très
important parce qu'effectivement à
debout la france on ne promet pas si
vous voulez des de la démagogie et le
retour de ce qu'ils étaient avant
il est évident que la nouvelle industrie
qui doit revenir en france sera de
l'industrie robotisés mais il faut aussi
dire aux français que la robotisation
crée aussi des emplois quand on compare
le nombre de robots qui existe dans
l'industrie allemande ou qui existe dans
l'industrie nord italienne par exemple
cela crée des emplois au final en fait
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait croire
dans le 21e siècle le sous-équipement de
l'industrie française
parce qu'en fait l'industrie française
manque de robots contribue au fait que
l'industrie française ne crée plus
d'emplois et décroche par rapport à ses
voisins donc il faut pas opposer se
pensent pas c'est ce que voulait faire
mais c'est parce qu'aimer pour que ce
soit bien clair auprès d'eux des
auditeurs il ne faut pas du tout opposé
la robotisation et la création d'emplois
industriels
moi c'est vraiment mon métier
fondamental les deux vont ensemble parce
qu'effectivement vous allez pas payer
des ouvriers et 800 euros comme en chine
on ne peut pas gagner la bataille des
bas salaires il faut gagner la bataille
de la qualification par contre là où je
compléterai ce qu'a dit monsieur pasquet
ckt départements français qui ont réussi
ce passage je pense notamment à la
vendée où effectivement un souverainiste
philippe de villiers a investi dans les
filières a investi dans laquelle
publication et vous avez des
départements france qui ont sauvé leur
industrie qui ont investi dans la ville
industrie d'avenir notamment la vendée
l'alsace donc tout n'est pas perdu
moi ce que je voudrais dire comme
mesalles sait aussi que ce sont les
hommes politiques qui ont
désindustrialisé la france en europe
l'allemagne n'a pas d industrialiser
l'italie nu d'or n'a pas d
industrialiser la suisse n'a pas dé
industralisés
ça a été une politique volontaire et les
nuls qui aujourd'hui veulent rétablir
lisf plus par démagogie sont les mêmes
que ceux qui ont désindustrialisé la
france volontairement en pensant qu'on
pourrait faire de la france un grand
supermarché et un site touristique et on
voit le résultat
ce n'est pas possible on il faut
vraiment que les français aussi rompent
rompent avec ces politiciens nul
incompétents qui ont mis le pays dans
cette situation et
la grande crainte que j'ai dans le monde
d'après c'est que ça repart comme avant
alors je voulais vous faire réagir sur
les propos de bruno le maire ministre
des finances matin sur une chaîne
d'information à la question faut-il
augmenter les impôts nos confrères et
ont posé cette question voici sa réponse
ce n'est pas une bonne stratégie nous
avons aujourd'hui une économie qui a
connu un choc d'une brutalité extrême
pour amortir ce choc
nous nous en béton et cette dette
effectivement il faudra la rembourser
pour rembourser cette dette je fais le
pari de la croissance c'est à dire du
retour de l'activité est pas celui des
impôts alors denis jacquet ça ça va
faire plaisir à tous les deux parce que
voilà bruno le maire qui parient sur le
retour de la croissance et surtout pas
sur celui de la hausse des impôts c'est
un voeu pieux ça va être possible ça
alors on a trois minutes en une minute
heure et demie ça qu'un ce serait
parfait messieurs coûté rapidement on
avait des perspectives de croissance qui
était en permanence revue soit à la
stagnation soit la baisse avant la crise
due qu'au guide
donc il ya malheureusement aucune raison
qu'ils aient une croissance extrêmement
importante dans un univers qui doit être
récessif
ce qu'on sait pas en plus c'est l'effet
boule de neige terre que vous savez que
pas seulement les marchés mais les
investisseurs sont très à l'écouté de ce
qui peut se passer à partir du moment où
tout le monde sombre un peu dans le
pessimisme et malheureusement les
chiffres vont nous faire sombrer dans le
pessimisme
ça va être une période des pagnes
vraisemblablement de sous investissement
parce qu'on n'aura peur de la durée de
la durée dans laquelle l'investissement
pour pouvoir revenir donc bien
évidemment bruno le maire si aujourd'hui
il ajoute du malheur au malheur en
disant non seulement on a une récession
mais en plus de les payer plus d'impôts
le pays s'écroule donc il ne peut pas
dire ça donc un moment donné on peut
s'endetter
la france fait partie des pays qui
peuvent encore eu malheureusement
s'endetter je dis bien malheureusement
parce qu'à un moment donné il faut quand
même payer un moment donné ça se traduit
par des impôts si c'est pas ce
gouvernement ce sera le suivant ou celui
d'après parce que là il ya des réalités
et puis il y aura des victimes
puisqu'avant donné il faudra aussi payer
des intérêts sur la dette à rembourser
cette dette est qu un moment on est
obligé de prendre dans un bus
et de faire des sacrifices pour pouvoir
continuer à payer ses fonctionnaires et
à payer le budget donc oui réponses
qu'on attendait on ne peut pas attendre
une autre réponse en ce moment sinon
c'est un cataclysme économique
on verra combien de temps ils seront
capables de tenir selon eux ce discours
e ou d'autres ça sera la même chose pour
tous on espère tous que ça pourra aller
mais en attendant une croissance très
honnêtement si quelqu'un peut prévoir de
la croissance une croissance durable
suffisamment haute pour recréer des
emplois dans les trois prochaines années
franchement là j'aimerais être au delà
de mon optimisme naturel jean philippe
tanguy aussi pessimistes denis jacquet
un mois de la fin très pessimiste sur
bruno le maire puisque le canard
enchaîné a révélé que le gouvernement
allait déjà augmenté les impôts
puisqu'ils vont prolonger la part de csg
et de crds qui amortit la dette sociale
etc comme 16 milliards d'euros par an
pendant 8 ans donc ils ont déjà augmenté
les impôts sans le dire comme toujours
malheureusement et moi je pense que la
seule solution c'est de changer modèle
de croissance on l'a dit le fabricant
france mais aussi la rupture écologique
les allemands viennent d'investir 9
milliards d'euros dans l'hydrogène
nous on investit 100 millions d'euros
vous voyez encore la différence nous à
deux bouts la france a fait dix ans
qu'on demande d'investir dans
l'hydrogène puisque c'est une des pistes
d'avenir pour remplacer rien que moi que
le pétrole donc il faut vraiment miser
sur les technologies d'avenir on a des
ingénieurs on a des savoir faire
il faut maintenant il faut bouger sinon
on va mourir merci à tous les deux jean
philippe tanguy denis jacquet d'avoir
été avec nous et de débattre sur qui va
rembourser cette dette abyssale après
cette crise sanitaire et cette crise
économique qui ne fait que commencer
merci à vous deux